I'm in meetings a lot my calendar gets
very full with those and then at night
after the kids have gone to bed I'm on
email a great deal I get messages during
the day that's my chance to give long
responses and then over the weekend I
send a lot of mail as well as well I
take two weeks a year to just go off and
read and think where I'm not interrupted
by work or anything else I'm just
solidly trying to think about the future
and people get to send me things to read
as part of that so-called think week so
it's a nice mix of things about 25% of
the time that I'm out traveling around
meeting with customers Europe Asia and
that sort of helps me think okay do we
have the right priorities what what are
people responding well to and what would
they they'd like to see us do better
first I met Warren we were talking about
getting together and doing something
again we pulled out his calendar and the
pages were so blank and I said wow you
know you've managed to avoid getting
tied in to a lot of kind of meaningless
activity and you know Warren said yeah
you have to be good at saying no and
picking the things that really make a
difference and that's one of many things
I've learned from warm but that's one of
my favorites and I so I can blame it on
him whenever I'm turning things down you
just watched two amazing clips with Bill
Gates take the next three minutes and
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]